here's a question not nearly as simple a
red zone out via twitter asks what's
more likely kyler murray wins the mvp
award or brian flores the dolphins is
the coach of the year peter what's more
likely
brian flores wins coach of the year
right now he's number two for me i got
mike tomlin one brian florey's too
right now kyler murray would be
knocking on the door of the top five but
i'd rather have my number two guy
uh as my option there because
hey if flory's if the dolphins win this
division
and if they play great down the stretch
uh i might vote for him over tomlin
anyway i think those are the guys who
right now to me are the two clear-cut
leaders for coach of the year
coach of the year to me is always the
coach who most exceeds the generally
accepted expectations for the team going
in yeah and the expectations for the
dolphins were just yeah yeah you know
and if they would make the playoffs or
win the division that's huge and that
really helps brian flores murray's got
to do a lot he's got to have a lot more
in his bag of tricks than yesterday's
hail mary to emerge as the mvp i hope he
does but i agree with you i think flores
is more likely to win
coach of the year than murray mvp all
right monday night football vikings
three and five bears five and four
i really do think both team seasons are
riding on this game peter whoever wins
still has a shot at the seventh seed
whoever loses i think is done do you
agree
um
yeah i mean
i think they're both dying you think
they're both done look
no i don't i like the vikings a lot
right now
because mike i think in the last two
weeks they've discovered exactly who
they are
in the last two weeks you know alexander
madison and of course dalvin cook have
averaged 224 yards
rushing per game in these two victories
that they have this is who they are as a
team this is what mike zimmer wants to
be
and in my opinion that's what you're
going to see at soldier field tonight
listen
this game the biggest over under don't
tell me about points tell me about time
over under
two hours 54 minutes give me the under
yeah i agree with you and i remember
last year very vividly when the vikings
looked like they had discovered this
dalvin cook formula the first time it
short circuited was at soldier field he
was held to 35 yards kirk cousins could
not buy time it was an ugly game if
dalvin cook can't run tonight this is
the opportunity for the bears and nick
foles who last saw the vikings in the
2017 nfc championship game to get to six
and four but i think whoever loses this
really is done it's kind of a mini
playoff game in mid-november everyone
enjoy the game tonight peter thanks for
joining us today we'll see everyone
tomorrow morning bright and early for
pft live have a great evening here's
safety blitz with rodney jack
collinsworth
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports